well thank you Max for the lovely
introduction
um so as mentioned my name's Robin I'm a
former mathematician turned software
engineer and uh I've ever since I left
Academia I've been working in startups
mostly in Berlin I'm currently working
for tactile we're a startup from Berlin
about 50 people I'm principal engineer
there but I just enjoy like wearing lots
of different hats that all being said
today we want to talk about Rusty python
um so I you know for everyone that has
been to the other talks you've probably
seen that there's been a lot of talks
about you know tools that use rust and
python together polar being an example
we had a couple talks yesterday and so I
guess today we want to figure out what
you know what is the hype all about
so
the talk will have three parts first
part is going to be an introduction into
rust for those of you that have never
seen rust maybe a quick you know show of
hands who here has worked with rust
before
all right so quite a few people I'm
probably not the expert in the room just
I have to point that out at this point
but cool um so this this will be an
introduction for everyone the second
part will be a bit of a toy example
where we we take a project and then we
used rust to speed it up and then the
third part I'll talk a little bit about
a project that we did internally at
tactile and what we learned from from
doing that
cool so uh starting out with what is
rust so rust is a modern compiled system
programming language that has been
created in 2015 so it's a very new
language compared to a lot of other
languages that we're using and it has a
similar performance and low level
control as C and C plus plus there is
some some theoretical reason of why it
could at some point actually be faster
than C plus plus the the reasoning being
that it feeds more information to
Downstream compilation steps llbm that
is but in practice it's mostly attached
slower just because less people use it
um I've linked the benchmarking game if
anyone is interested in the details here
and one thing that it really focuses on
is a it prioritizes memory safety and
threat safety and I'll show you some
cool features of rust that make this
quite elegant to you know adhere to in
comparison to languages such as C plus
um so you know let's let's talk about
some things that are awesome about rust
um one thing that I that I really like
it has modern batteries include a
tooling cargo
um so there's there's one uh canonical
way of creating projects building
project testing projects documenting
them and Publishing them I wish python
had something like this I think in
internally at tactile we have about
three different ways of packaging python
applications which is not great
um we need some some uniformity here
um one thing that is maybe not as
interesting for the python Community but
um for people that have worked with C
plus plus before cross compilation
support is actually really good at in in
Rust so compiling on on you know a
MacBook with um you know an AMD 64 chip
for example into for targeting lambdas
with maybe a different insta compile
with a different CPU is actually really
straightforward
um other things that are that are really
awesome about rust is uh one of it is
has a docs.rs it's a page where whenever
you publish a package it hosts the
documentation so that's a really cool
thing because it you know has links
between the different packages it's
really easy to see
um you know what's the documentation of
the package that I'm currently using
and this gets us to the the first kind
of special feature all of these things
are just like you know modern language
type features but here ownership
semantics is one of the things that
really um is different about rust so I
got an example here uh we're defining a
string as one and we're um you know
setting it to the string hello and then
we're saying let S2 be equal to S1 so at
this point a few things could happen uh
what actually happens in Rust is that
the the ownership moves from S1 to S2 so
as one is then actually pointing at
nothing and the the compiler will make
sure that you don't accidentally use S1
after you've done something like that so
I've included a compiler Arrow here now
this at first might seem really annoying
to deal with but when it comes to not
having multiple mutable references to an
object this stuff is really really handy
and um The Sibling or the cousin of the
ownership semantics is a so-called
lifetime tracking so what happens here
is we have a variable X which we set to
five and then we Define a reference and
we refer to this X and then we try to
use the reference after X doesn't exist
anymore so you know X will go out of
scope on the closing curly brace and
again rust will prevent us from writing
code like this and this um basically
alleviates a whole class of of dangling
pointer issues that were with you know
commonplace and C and C plus
one thing that I personally find very
interesting is uh it has a very
expressive macro system it's a compile
time expression if you have no idea what
this means you can think of like python
decorators they are used mostly in
similar circumstances and here's a
couple of examples one of them being we
Define a new type message and the
message is an email me can either be a
request or response and then just by
putting these couple tags on top there
we uh we define derived
serialize and deserialize functionality
and we also make it work with this enum
so basically what this does is it writes
the rust code for turning this into Json
and then parsing it back from Json but
also figuring out which of the two it is
based on the type field
and uh I got one more example because I
find this so cool is um the sqlx sqlx is
kind of a new take on the orm problem or
M problem being that or Ms are
complicated beasts and basically what
this does is you give it a SQL
expression and it will in during compile
time figure out if a the SQL expression
makes sense against your database and B
it will also write all the serialization
code to turn it into the object that you
wanted so in this case into a country so
it's like
crazy crazy stuff that is possible
um that being said this is a python
conference so you know let's also talk
about some things that are terrible
about rust and and they definitely are
um so I mean it's a compiled language
but not only you know is it compiled
it's also really slow at times so
they've there's been a lot of work on
this and you know hot reloading is is
getting better but
um it's still like you know you will be
waiting a lot for your code to compile
I personally find Rust to be at times
quite verbose especially if you come
from python so you know make sure that
you you'll be spending a lot of time or
I guess lines of code massaging the data
to you know have the right types to for
the compiler to accept
and then lastly my experience anyway is
like I I've noticed that when whenever I
I write rust code and things get a
little bit more complicated and I have
to actually help the compiler with the
lifetime parameters then stuff feels
like you know kind of solving a jigsaw
puzzle at times so it's kind of trying
to convince the compiler that you know
this is actually valid code
so let's talk a little bit about
um the tooling so there's three General
um categories of toolings the first one
is bindings to python so these are
basically libraries that let you bind
rust code to python code pyo 3 is by far
the most popular one and it's also the
one that we'll be using it has a lot of
cool
um extra extra add-ons one of them for
example being an async IO add-on that
allows you to tie python async code to
rust async code by passing Futures back
and forth between the two languages so
it's really cool uh really cool project
um the second category is uh setup tools
extension so once I have a way of of
linking the actual languages there's
still the question how do I set up like
a build environment that then you know
builds the python code but also builds
the the rust code and and links it
together and there's multiple multiple
projects here maturing is is the most
famous one they Pride themselves as
being zero configuration tooling and I
this is also my experience like unless
you do something really crazy most of
like most likely it's just going to work
out of the box
and um there's a third category and I
have no idea what to put as a a category
here there's an umbrella project called
Pi oxidizer and they they do a lot of
things they they provide tooling for
shipping Python scripts as executables
um they try to rewrite see Python and
rust and they also have a way of
embedding statically linking
python into rust applications I yeah if
anyone has a good suggestion on what to
put here um please tell me
cool so this takes us to the second part
um let's speed up some python code so I
wanted to do something visual so that
you know we get we have something to see
so basically it was either a manual
broad or Ray Tracer I decided to go over
the ray tracing part this time
um this is just the the wrapping code
um it uses Pi game to create a window
800 times 600 pixels and then what we do
is we just kind of walk pixel by pixel
and we calculate the color of every
pixel so if you run this code and we can
do it maybe later in the Q a section and
you see that you know it starts all
black and then the plexus seats and and
the actual image comes out
um yeah I think this
probably not not a lot of questions so
this is the actual logic of what we're
doing here
um let's maybe focus on that on the the
sketch we're just sending in a light Ray
from the screen and then we see if we
hit us so our our scene consists of a
sphere and a light and the only thing we
do is we send this light rain and we see
if we intersect the sphere and if we do
then we calculate the angle towards the
light sphere and based on that we color
the point
um the important piece here is that we
want to keep the logic in Python because
we like you know the expressiveness that
python has but there's three classes in
here that we use it's VEC line and
sphere and these are you know three
python classes that I've created for
this and the idea is that we want to
replace those by rust and see if this
gives us any speed up
so here are the implementation of Vex
sphere and line I don't think there's a
lot of interesting stuff here we add
some Dunder methods so that we can
actually add vectors and multiply them
and maybe there's one interesting piece
is the sphere but it's the intersection
between a line and a sphere but it's
really an exercise in quadratic formula
so you know read it if you if you're
interested but it's probably not the
main focus
so the the number one thing of course
with profiling is always make sure that
we're that we're optimizing the right
thing so let's first figure out if you
know what is actually the slow part in
our code and I like to use snake whiz
for this with the inter built-in C
profile module of python
um so if you do this if you run these
commands you you get this flame graph
type of graph the only thing that you
have to be really careful about here is
that the proportions are not right so
the purple bar for example is almost the
same time as the blue bar even though
they look like you know completely
different sizes
and um if you if you look now you see
that the ray Trace color that's the the
gray box up there takes about 27.3
seconds which uh given an overall run
time of 43 seconds is about three
quarters of the time spent in this color
function so it's it's a reasonable
Target to optimize I guess
um to make this a little bit more
concrete
um you know I I put some uh measuring
instrumentation on the color function
itself and if you do that and you plot
the histogram that derives from it you
get the following image so these are
nanoseconds on the x-axis and
distribution on the y-axis so we see
that on average we're spending about
11.8 milliseconds per execution of the
color function note one thing that you
know I put the the average there and the
standard deviation but I also plotted
the normal distribution the stuff is
absolutely not normally distributed as
many things are in in real life just as
a reminder
um so let's let's optimize this uh how
do we do this well you know we're using
Maturin if we just run maturing new rust
rust is the name of the library that
we're giving here uh we we get asked
what kind of bindings we want to use so
we just say Pi O3 so once this is done
we we can you know see there's a new
directory of rest and in there we have a
Pi Project tunnel ellip.rs file in a
cargo tunnel so I'm assuming everyone is
familiar with what a Pi Project tunnel
is lib.rs is basically where the rust
code will go and cargo.com is basically
the equivalent of um the pi project.to
but on on Rust side so it'll include
stuff like
um your the name of your library and the
dependencies and licensing information
and so on and so forth if you look into
the pi projector tunnel you see that
there's a build back and maturing
specified here so this uses a PP
extension for the buildback and I think
517 if I'm not mistaken and and this
allows you to hook into other tools to
build your python project so what this
means is that you can use standard uh
ways of building python project packages
here I'm using the build module and it
will just work out of the box it will
then call mature into compile the rust
code and you end up with a source
distribution and
a Wheels file if you run this
so let's Implement Vector uh so for you
know for Vector we Define a new struct
that has three values x y and z um all
of them are F 32 types and and then we
Implement a bunch of methods on it and
they basically are just a copy paste of
what we did on on the python side of
things so you know we have it under add
to add two vectors and under sub to take
the difference of two now I already
mentioned the macro system of rust and
and here it it shows how you know how it
can shine so we have this Pi class macro
as well as Pi methods and new and this
is basically for creating all of The
Binding clue code that will make these
objects also work with on the patent
side of things
so if I now just you know after adding
this code run mature and develop and
then what happens is it it'll build the
package and it'll install it into a
virtual environment I can then start a
rust Rebel and just import rust and uh
start calling rust.vec123 and you know
print it and everything maybe one
important part here I on the on the
bottom right you see I I defined an
underscore like a thunder representation
this is of course important because
otherwise you won't get nice printouts
of the vectors but it'll be only like
some kind of built-in type
cool so this is the implementation of
sphere and uh yeah sphere just sphere
um I I don't think you know there's
anything particularly interesting in the
code uh all of The Code by the way is on
GitHub if you're interested in it um so
go take a look and then finally we have
line again not super interesting but uh
there's one one final piece which is
this Pi module object
um at the end so like in in Python every
every module has an initialization
function and this basically creates the
initialization function for the module
and uh here what we do is we basically
add these three objects or the three
classes to our module which are vax
sphere and line
cool so then the only thing that we have
to do is we have to change the import so
rather than from python import
backsphere and line we do from rust
import vexphere and line and if we run
the whole thing again we see that
basically the performance has changed
quite a bit so instead of taking about
11.8 milliseconds per run of
um color it now takes about four
milliseconds to run of color so just to
understand these graphs I probably
should have put this on the slide like
the left side is the python um variant
that we used before and the right side
is rust
which is pretty impressive considering
that the actual logic is still in Python
so this is a bit of you know how I think
about all these different solutions of
speeding up rust so given the time I
think we probably should skip this slide
but until the hour is like you know it's
it's still like a very heavyweight thing
to do and there's probably a lot of
other ways of optimizing your python
code that you should try first
cool so um last case or last part is the
case study uh so I here I'll have to
tell you as a very brief introduction
into what do we actually do at tactile
so we're a bit in we're in the
decisioning space so what does that mean
that means that our customers give
decisioning logic to us and we turn this
into apis so you can think of
decisioning logic as a graph as on the
left side so there's little python
Snippets that are connected in a graph
and then we have to turn this into an
API that they can call and and execute
their logic for them
so um this part is a bit slow or some of
our customers think it's a tattoo slow
so you know the question was can we
maybe use rust to optimize this
so first uh let's let's talk a little
bit about how slow is slow so we're
talking about a in in the best case if
we have a really easy decisioning logic
um we're talking about about 200
millisecond response time and of that
200 milliseconds
um about 100 milliseconds is actually
spent executing um the graph the rest of
it is other Lambda functions or API
gateways or Cache reads or stuff like
that so we're looking at a a ray Trace
snapshot here of of a call that is about
200 milliseconds in total and we spend
about 100 milliseconds executing the
graph
so you know we asked ourselves this
question
um uh despite can we rewrite the
execution logic in Rust and um
to give you some data about what does
that mean so you know the project that
we're looking at is about we have a
Lambda which is only about 870 lines of
python code and then we have a package
which is about 19k of lines of python
code that we install in there so we're
talking about 20K lines so it's not not
a very big project but it's also not a
trivial project
um
and so the time box that we said we
don't want to spend too much time on
this because you know you you can do
this forever
um question is like three work days one
developer how far can we get and you
know is this a feasible way of speeding
things up
uh yeah goal is
set up a proof of concept for for
running our execution in Rust and then
you know remember that there's these
little python Snippets so the question
was can we run this thing itself in rest
and call out to python for executing the
logic
and um given all these constraints we
figured the only thing that makes sense
is to try to implement a vertical slice
so we take one type of API call and
Implement that end to end but we don't
try to actually have full feature
completeness because that's just
undoable within three workdays
so this is how the timeline went
um the green Parts is basically us
figuring out how to do this
um like how to statically link python
into rust and how to cross compile the
whole thing to Lambda I also think as
far as I can tell there was no one else
that has tried this before at least
there was not no traces of it on the
internet so if you're interested I got
some hints in the GitHub repository and
how to do it
um so after the first day we got a um
hello world to run we were able to run
python code within a rust slum there so
that was does a great moment
then the second day you know the purple
stuff is where we actually spend time
implementing our vertical slice
um we unfortunately hit some SEC faults
at the end of the second day and it was
very hard to debug those I don't know if
anyone's ever tried to debug SEC faults
in lambdas but it's really not a lot of
fun
um and we also never really understood
where they came from we found a way that
so that they don't appear but just like
you know fair warning here is there's
probably some some dangerous lurking in
in our solution
um at in any way at the you know mid
point of day three we were able to
successfully call the the vertical slice
um we were very happy about that and we
then spent some more time trying to like
SN malok is a is a different memory
allocator from Microsoft that um that is
supposedly a bit faster we try to
compile it against that but it didn't
work so you know we unfortunately wasted
that time
um so what are the results first off
there's some stuff that went really well
so first off we managed to actually get
the thing to work which is impressive in
my opinion and the second thing is it's
actually quite a bit faster so we're
talking about from the 100 milliseconds
that we spent before we're now down to
about 40 milliseconds which is great but
we also have to remember that you know
it's it's only about uh half of the time
is spent executing the um the
decisioning logic so overall it's only a
30 percent uh speed up of the response
time
and you know here here we get to the
truth well you know we have a 30 speed
up of the response time but we also had
a significant trouble with that non-pure
python dependencies so I think or Jason
didn't work at all so we had to give up
on using it pandas we got to work but
you know every every patent dependency
that is not pure pure python is going to
be major pain for us going forward
um it had a lot of complexity or
develops to our developer setup so you
know now instead of just having a single
language we have to deal with and set up
tooling for we have to do it for
multiple languages
we also had a strong suspicion that
while the speed up was impressive it
most likely
um would have not survived if we
expanded the vertical slice in the same
order of magnitude so you know I mean
probably looking at more like over 20
speed up once we implement it or we
widened the slice
um and then yeah as I mentioned
debugging stack Falls is not fun and at
this point I realized how lucky we are
that we're using python mostly at
tactile and yeah
there's also a couple of meta points
that I think one should not
underestimate um one of them is that we
don't have a lot of rest experience
in-house
um and the other thing is it's I you
know from talking to other developers
it's it's really hard and expensive to
hire rust Developers
um so for now we will not go ahead I
think we learned a lot it was a really
cool project and uh yeah I I wouldn't
miss the time but um
given all these constraints it probably
doesn't make sense for us to continue
down this path
um yeah as mentioned I got some some
artifacts on GitHub who's interested
thank you very much
and thank you Robin that was a really
interesting talk I really like the part
where you actually you shared your
experience of actually doing this in
your organization I think that gave me
some context for maybe what I'm going to
try and push to let my boss let me do
for three days maybe but we've got quite
a few questions for you so we've only
got a few minutes so I'll ask just the
top rated ones okay um but look yeah so
we'll do our best here to get through as
many but if not Robin will be around for
the conference so please do come and
find them
um so first of all question for you how
is Rusty python how is that speed up
comparable to scython or python with
Julia for example yeah it's a very
interesting question I mean I I don't
have that much experience with python
for Julia I actually saw sat through the
tutorial yesterday that's my only
exposure to it and um so my my strong
suspicion is that both um Julia and
saitan are probably have a lower
performance cap so like if you really go
down to the nitty-gritty details most
likely you can do more stuff with rust
and C plus plus than you can do with
Julia siphon but of course like you
should still try these other options
because they are much more lightweight
and much easier to implement than what
I've shown today
cool thank you thank you for that next
question comes from Anonymous who's
asking the question what tool do you use
if you need to debug rust code so the
tools like ipdb work when you're mixing
both Python and rust yeah I mean
honestly most of my experience has not
relied on debugging tools per se I'm
just from I'm I'm not a debugging type
of developer my my my yeah
now in the sense there there's some
there's some people that really enjoy
using debuggers I'm I'm not I I find it
more like reasoning through code and
putting a couple of good print
statements is always easier for me then
so unfortunately I can't help you with
this that's that's I mean I I would be
lying if I said I'd never just written
here and then move that line down to
find what my problem was so fair enough
and it's very mathematical as an
approach as well you know you prove that
part works I like that
um so just a couple minutes left so a
few more questions
um is there a setting in which you
prefer jit tools like number over rust
for speeding on python I mean I I think
you should try these tools first because
they they are out there you know they're
well supported there's lots of
documentation and most likely it's going
to be much much faster to get it to work
and if you hit any Corner cases there's
actually people to talk to rather than
just no one like like we hit here
um that being said I mean I'm I'm
definitely not a you know data engineer
so I I don't have too much experience
with what uh the Restriction of number I
have for example so I I know for pandas
and stuff it gets tricky if it's not a
flat data frame type of
um number crunching job that you have so
I would say try to use these tools if
you can and if not then you have to
resort to something like this
awesome thank you
um so another question we've got here
another one from Anonymous is uh when is
learning rust which they identify as
being very distinct from python
um you know you're losing certain things
like you're losing introspection and you
have extra build steps when is that when
is that worth it would you say when is
it worth it to actually consider using
rust I think it's worth to learn it full
stop um just because it's a very
interesting language that has brings new
stuff to the table and that being said
the question I think should be kind of
like when is it worth using it and then
it comes kind of back to the trade-offs
we're talking to where I think most of
the stuff
like python is just so much more
expressive and so much more quick to
write
um I I would default to using python
sure and we've just got time maybe for
one more question unfortunately there's
some great ones coming in and I'm
enjoying reading and uh I think maybe
yeah if we find Robin at some point
afterwards I'm sure you can stick around
for a little bit maybe just outside
um but just one for now just before we
go and why was Russ the choice for the
speed of MVP compared to something like
you know pure siphon
um I don't know just personal preference
okay okay I guess we got time for one
more in that case quick answer uh thank
you Mustafa for that question one last
one when is using rust with python a
better solution than using numpy or
something similar
yeah I I think kind of goes back to the
the thing that I said before like you
know if you can use numpy use numpy
really because it's you know it's
documented it's you know there's a lot
of other people out there that use it
but if you can before using C plus plus
to speed it up think about using rest
cool Robin thank you so much this is
great please give him give a big big
round of applause again thank you so
much